there are two dogs counting on your
fingers one two - haha that's fantastic
oh my god we got chica chica right don't
number one doc no dog number one number
one dog first dog to give well that got
that got gotten by mark and then second
dog that I snuck into the house late at
night one night while I wasn't here
without Mark's permission the Lego I
will see how he'll see how long that
lasts
take a look go get it take it go here
chicken go get him
chica kill him kill him Lego Tom you
know Lego you kill him first let go kill
him Pharrell
let go kill him first kill eat him home
and kill Lego what are you doing eat
Gingka
now go eat him Jakob first Lego I know
first one treat up yeah first one they
kill him using a treat kill kill him
kill him kill ya know you're confused
still right hand wait I have an idea
chicken come here please it I'm gonna do
the patent is puppy food glittery device
oh yeah